Yes!
You're halfway through
the course content.
Now it's time for the fun part.
Working on the first
version of the meme app.
Your chance to put into practice what
you've learned about constraints,
UI controls, text field delegates,
and modeling presented views.
The next lesson has a different tone.
It's a self guided format for
working through the particular
skills necessary for meme.
We're going to ask you to look
into a few new topics as well.
Like keyboard animations and
notifications.
But don't worry, I'll guide you
through the trickiest parts.
You've done an excellent job
making it to this point.
Now get psyched to start
on the portfolio project.